tenemos el número complejo 3 menos 4 y
graficado en el plano complejo y eso me
está diciendo que su parte real es 3 así
que nos movemos 3 unidades a la derecha
sobre este eje que es el eje real y
luego nos movemos 4 hacia abajo en el
eje imaginario verdad que es el eje
vertical entonces nos movemos a menos 4
que son 4 unidades hacia abajo y en
conjunto nos dan la ubicación del punto
3 menos 4
y quiero ahora realmente pensar cuánto
vale el valor absoluto de 3 menos 4 y y
realmente el valor absoluto no es otra
cosa más que la distancia que hay del
del punto
en el plano al 0 oa lo que es el origen
entonces necesitamos calcular esta
distancia y lo que vamos a hacer es
construir un triángulo rectángulo y
después utilizamos el teorema de
pitágoras vamos a construir el triángulo
que tiene este vértice este otro y éste
último al final ok entonces si construya
este triángulo
darnos cuenta que esta altura esta
altura es justamente es justamente 4 voy
a ponerlo con el color del 4 entonces
esta altura mide justamente 4 muy bien y
la base de nuestro triángulo rectángulo
es justamente 3 verdad que es la parte
real de eso entonces como este triángulo
es rectángulo podemos utilizar
inmediatamente el teorema de pitágoras
que me dice que la base al cuadrado con
un cateto al cuadrado más más el otro el
lado al cuadrado o el otro cateto al
cuadrado debe ser igual esto es igual a
la distancia de la hipotenusa a la la
magnitud de la hipotenusa al cuadrado
pero la hipotenusa es el valor absoluto
de 3 menos 4 y así que vamos a ponerlo
así el valor absoluto de 3 menos 4 y y
tenemos que sacarle el cuadrado a eso
muy bien entonces esto debería ser muy
sencillo porque 3 al cuadrado es 9
y menos 4 al cuadrado es 16 y 9 más 16
son justamente 25 y eso corresponde al
valor absoluto juego en algunos lados
también le llaman módulo pero vamos a
llamarle aquí valor absoluto de 3 menos
4 y y eso va al cuadrado si sacamos raíz
cuadrada y realmente sólo nos quedamos
con la raíz positiva porque es una
distancia o la raíz principal eso nos
dice que el módulo o el valor absoluto
es 5
eso es el valor absoluto el valor
absoluto de 3 menos 4 y muy bien
entonces con esto ya hemos obtenido el
valor absoluto de 3 menos 4 y ahora bien
simplemente podrías pensar que tomamos
la parte real al cuadrado luego la parte
imaginaria al cuadrado lo sumamos y
luego sacamos raíz cuadrada pero bueno
esto lo hice para que tú vieras bien la
noción geométrica de que estamos
haciendo entonces esencialmente nada más
nos tomamos la raíz cuadrada de la parte
real al cuadrado que en este caso es
bueno 3 al cuadrado
más la parte imaginaria al cuadrado y
luego esto sería igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 9 16 y más perdón más 16
verdad simplemente nos tomamos la parte
real y lo elevamos al cuadrado y eso
nuevamente vuelve a ser 5